nos dicen las dos siguientes ecuaciones
forman un sistema lineal y aquí tenemos
ecuaciones con xy con date cuenta por lo
tanto estamos definiendo una recta y
aquí tengo otra ecuación con x con lo
cual también quiere decir que definimos
una recta gráfica el sistema y encuentra
su solución y si te das cuenta acá abajo
nos dan nuestra gráfica en donde podemos
interactuar con la página podemos tomar
estos puntos y moverlos y así vamos a ir
definiendo a nuestra recta así que para
ello vamos a tener dos ecuaciones dos
rectas y después vamos a ver en donde se
intersectan aquí tengo mi primera recta
vamos a fijarnos en ella nos dicen 5 x
menos 10 james es igual a 20 y bueno qué
te parece si nosotros nos fijamos en dos
puntos muy sencillos para esta recta lo
que voy a hacer es preguntarme qué va a
pasar cuando x vale 0 para así poder
encontrar uno de los puntos de mi recta
y después preguntarme qué es lo que va a
pasar cuando llévale cero para encontrar
segundo punto de mi recta y así poder
graficar d así que empecemos qué pasa
cuando x vale 0 bueno cuando x vale 0
date cuenta de que en 5 x 0 esto es 0 y
simple y sencillamente me quedo con
menos 10 igual a 20 déjame ponerlo aquí
menos 10 y es igual a 20 porque esto se
va menos 10 igual a 20 eso quiere decir
que el valor de ya que tomaría sería de
menos 2 pasó a este dividiendo y me
quedaría igual a menos 2 así que cuando
x vale cero y vale menos dos vamos a
bajar esta pantalla para ponerlo aquí en
mi gráfica que tengo cuando x vale cero
cuando x vale cero que vale menos dos
uno
negativo así que ya tengo mi primer
punto para mi primera ecuación vamos a
ver ahora qué es lo que pasa cuando vale
cero bueno cuando lleva de cero esta
parte de aquí menos 10 también vale cero
porque cero por lo que sea es cero y
solamente me voy a quedar con 5 x 5 x
igual a 20 para que valor de x 5x es
igual a 20 o dicho de otra manera si
paso el 5 del otro lado dividiendo me va
a quedar que x es igual a 4 cuando
llévales 0 x vale 4 así que vamos a
ocuparlo en mi otro punto voy a bajar
por acá y voy a poner cuando x vale 4
x baile 4 que vale 0 cuando vale 0 x
vale 4 y perfecto ya tengo dos puntos y
por lo tanto ya tengo definida mi
primera recta y mi primera ecuación muy
bien ya tenemos la primera recta así que
vamos a subir y vamos a pensar en la
otra la tengo por aquí índice 2 x 4 y es
igual a 16 negativo qué va a pasar
cuando x vale 0 bueno cuando x vale 0 2x
también vale 0 y solamente me quedaría
con cuatro y igual a menos 16 o de otra
manera si paso este 4 dividiendo me va a
quedar que jeff es igual a menos 16
entre 4 lo cual es menos cuatro cuando x
vale cero que vale menos cuatro así que
vamos a poner ese punto por acá voy a
bajar para esto mi pantalla y dice
cuando x vale cero lleva el de 4
negativo es justo aquí x vale 0 lleva l
4 negativo ahora veamos nuestro segundo
punto que vamos a hacer cuando llévale 0
bueno vamos a suponer que lleva de 0 y
me queda
2x igual a menos 16 o dicho otra manera
x es igual a menos 8 menos 16 entre 2 es
menos 8 así que cuando lleva la 0 x vale
menos 8 vamos a poner ese punto por acá
cuando x valga menos 8 hierro vale 0 es
justo este valor cuando llévale 0 x vale
menos 8 y ya con esto tenemos la segunda
recta definida ahora lo que nos piden
también es encontrar la solución del
sistema es decir me voy a fijar en un
punto que se cumpla para ambas
ecuaciones es decir vamos a querer las x
siempre que cumplan
ambas ecuaciones y para eso me voy a
fijar en algún punto que esté en ambas
rectas para eso bajemos por acá y vamos
a fijarnos en un punto que exista en
ambas rectas y si te das cuenta es justo
el punto de intersección que es este de
aquí este va a ser mi punto solución y
de hecho es bastante claro es el punto
en donde
vale menos 2 y vale menos 3 por lo tanto
cuando x vale menos 2 y lleva le menos 3
vamos a estar en nuestra solución cuando
x vale menos dos menos 2 y llévale menos
3 entonces estaremos en nuestra solución
así que vamos a comprobar respuesta y
bien estamos bien así que vamos a hacer
otro par de ejercicios para seguir con
esto bien mi siguiente problema es este
un sistema de dos ecuaciones lineales
esta gráfica dow acá abajo da una
aproximación a la solución del sistema
así que date cuenta de que en esta
ocasión ya tenemos la gráfica de mis dos
ecuaciones ya tengo las dos rectas en
este plano por lo tanto lo que necesito
saber es donde se intersectan y dar una
aproximación a la solución y si te das
cuenta donde se intersectan es aquí en
este punto que tenemos aquí por lo tanto
lo que necesito encontrar es una
aproximación a la solución es decir que
el valor de x
y tomamos en este punto y si te das
cuenta x toma un valor entre menos 6 y
menos 5 está más pegado al menos 6 que
al menos 5 así que si por aquí tengo al
menos 5.5 por acá tendré al menos 5
punto como al menos 5.7 así que vamos a
ponerlo x tomaría el valor de menos 5.7
ok ahora vamos a fijarnos en gimp y si
te das cuenta que está entre 0 y 1 está
entre 0 y 1 y si por aquí está el 0.5 y
está un poquito más arriba pero muy
poquito que 0.5 va a estar cerca del 0.6
lo bueno es que nos piden una
aproximación así que vamos a ponerlo 0.6
yo creo que esa sería una buena
aproximación para mi punto solución es
decir para el punto donde se intersectan
las dos y vamos a comprobar si estamos
bien
y de lujo estamos bien vamos a hacer uno
más y con eso acabamos bien pues ahora
tenemos a este dice las siguientes dos
ecuaciones forman un sistema lineal y
aquí tengo ahora mis ecuaciones pero
vistas en la forma pendiente ordenada el
origen gráfica el sistema y encuentra su
solución y bueno para eso tenemos por
acá mis dos rectas que hay que graficar
bien vamos a pensar en la primera dice
que es igual a menos 7 x más 5 si x vale
0 entonces esta parte se va y nos
quedamos con la intersección con el eje
y es decir con 5 por lo tanto cuando x
vale 0
llévales 5 y lo voy a poner aquí le vale
5 cuando x vale 0 y estaríamos en este
punto de aquí ahora vamos a pensar qué
es lo que nos dice esta ecuación tenemos
una pendiente de menos 7 lo que quiere
decir que cuando x aumenta en 1 que
decrece en 7
vamos a hacerlo por acá abajo cuando
x aumenta en 1 estamos aumentando una
unidad que decrece en 7 así que iríamos
1 2 3 4 5
ciudades hacia abajo cuando x aumenta en
una unidad vamos a decrecer 7 1 2 3 4 5
6 7 es justo lo que me dice mi pendiente
por eso tengo una pendiente de menos 7
vamos a hacer lo mismo con mi segunda
ecuación y es igual a menos x menos 7
por lo tanto cuando x vale 0
entonces me queda que vale menos 7 ni
intersección con el eje y es igual a
menos 7 así que lo voy a poner aquí
cuando x vale 0 que vale menos 7
estaríamos en este punto de aquí y ahora
vamos a fijarnos en la pendiente para
ver cuánto aumenta x a comparación de y
dice que mi pendiente es menos 1 eso
quiere decir que cuando aumenta x en 1 y
decrece en 1 vamos a usarlo para poner
mi segundo punto cuando a justo estamos
aquí cuando x aumenta en 1
llegaríamos a este valor cuando x
aumenta en 1 y decrece en 1 y por eso
tengo una pendiente de menos 1 y después
nos piden cuál es la solución del
sistema gráfica el sistema y encuentra
su solución por lo tanto vamos a
fijarnos en el punto de intersección mi
punto de intersección es éste cuando x
vale 2 y que vale menos 9 así que vamos
a escribirlo cuando x vale 2 y llévale
menos 9 así que es hora de comprobar
respuesta y de lujo estamos bien